[Music]
you know what time it is
sony have unveiled the playstation plus
games for august 2020
and it's a great month in my opinion
this month the games download on
different days so i'll be sure to shout
them out
first off is fall guys i've been waiting
for this for so long this is technically
a battle royale game in which only one
person can win
from 60 starting contestants the game is
made up of 25 mini-games
randomly selected until a winner is
crowned such a simple concept but
believe me
it's great it's possible to team up with
your friends and although you will be
against each other for the majority of
the game
you are guaranteed to be with your
friends during team-based
rounds if you've ever watched tekeshi's
castle or it's a knockout in the uk
you know what to expect complete chaos
and shenanigans
the game is a mixture of skill but
mainly its luck and timing
which makes it a great party game we
only have three abilities other than
running
jumping diving and grabbing the grabbing
parts
can be used to murk people which may see
a controller or two be thrown against
the wall
yes i did that but if you get in the
mindset of having fun and not winning
this is a great game i highly recommend
it there will be battle passes
introduced to unlock skins emotes and
colour schemes
to have your fall guy look exactly as
you want them to
as soon as custom games are available
i'll be getting as many of you guys as i
can together
to play as one big grenade family by the
way i'll link a video of my son and i
playing the pc beta last week if you
want to see what a full game looks like
fall guys is downloadable from tuesday
the 4th of august
the next game is another beast call of
duty modern warfare 2
remastered reliving the campaign which
made so many of us fall in love with
task force 141
price ghost gaz soap the gun play in the
remaster is sublime
and the updated graphics look on point
throughout and i'm sure you remember the
museum after finishing the game all
those years ago
well it's here too and it's just as
great as you remember
the story is gripping the set piece is
bombastic and overall this is a high
quality game to play
especially for free if you're a war zone
player you'll recognize many locations
in the game
including the original gulag i hope you
escape it this time
if you want to see the easter eggs and
secrets to look out for i have a video
for you
and you can see some of the unlockable
modifiers too the only thing to note is
that the multiplayer mode is not
included in this version of the game
this is a solo campaign only but don't
worry here's the best news of all
it's downloadable from tomorrow tuesday
the 28th of july
wow impressive so there we have it what
do you think
sadly i can't run a poll anymore for you
guys to rate the month but i still want
to know your thoughts
4 guys and modern warfare 2 ps plus is
looking great right now
i'm adam from playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure i'll see you next time